I have been getting a loop run injection every three months, seven months, seven months total so far,
four metastatic prostate cancer, and PSA, my PSA levels, has consistently registered less than 0.1.
Recently, my oncologist has suggested, oh no, so let's back up this a little bit. I did not look this
person up who did this, but if your PSA is less than 0.1, it's a good possibility that they had
their prostate removed. So when a person has prostate cancer, and they're doing loop run,
if they still have a prostate, lots of times their PSA won't go this low. But if you don't have a
prostate, it's your PSA should stay this low when you're doing loop run. So loop run is an
androgen depravation drug. So it just removes all your testosterone. That's what loop run does.
Okay, sorry, continue. Recently, my oncologist has suggested I start taking this other drug,
orally four times a day together with a steroid, as this other drug can cause electrolytes to
decrease. If you don't take it with a steroid, I was told, this combination of world drugs together
with loop run injections can extend the time period that my PSA will stay at a low level. So understand,
using it, androgen depravation therapy drug like loop run, there's several others on the market.
Typically, we'll work wonders to drop a person's PSA don't in the takes, but it typically just
historic use of it will only keep PSA levels there for two to five years, and then all of a sudden
they just start going up. And they don't know completely why, except I'll tell you in a second.
Since taking this drug plus prednisone is a lifetime medication, what I'm told,
and someone has to begin this additional treatment, wonder if there's other things I can do.
Well, I did write a blog about this a couple of years ago, because this phenomenon
androgen depravation therapy working for a period of time in the stop, it stops working,
has been known for quite some time. And there's actually data and why they think it actually happens,
it has to do with the receptors, the energy receptors that it's working on. And this is the blog post
that I wrote on it, so go to this blog post, because it's been proven that two different things,
andrographic and EGCG, and I would add curcumin and reservoir trawl to this as well.
Work on that receptor to remove IL-6 interleukin-6 expression at that receptor,
and will help a person be able to get the same benefits from energy deprivation therapy for
a longer period of time without having to take those other drugs. And it's pretty easy to get
those these nutrients. And in this blog post, I actually tell you exactly what to take
to get this. So, read that blog post, just search in the blogs, I can write there,
the blogs just search right there, four prostate cancer, four-mode health and regulation,
and you see what I wrote about it. I'll put you in the description.